on va démarrer cette troisième partie
avec les terribles images qui nous
viennent d'angleterre à londres
un couple lesbien a été violemment prise
à partie par un groupe d'adolescents
dans un bus c'est le 20 heures de france
2 qui est revenu sur cette affreuse
agression le visage en sang sur cette
photo les deux jeunes femmes
apparaissent terrorisés dans un bus
londonien qui les ramène chez elle après
une soirée en couple il est 2h30 du
matin quelques minutes plus tôt au moins
quatre adolescents les accoste et leur
demande de s'embrasser en tenant des
propos homophobes
j'ai commencé à nous harceler de manière
très agressive l'un d'entre eux est
resté quelques rangs derrière et nous
jeter des pièces de monnaie ensuite ils
ont commencé à nous frapper et en
quelques instants
ils ont pris mon téléphone et saissac et
se sont enfuis en courant
si ces deux femmes décident aujourd'hui
de prendre la parole c'est pour distel
faire passer un message de tolérance
je veux que les gens se sentent libres
de lutter contre ceux qui ont
l'impression d'être dans la bonne voie
en agissant ainsi influencé par certains
discours extrêmes scotland yard a lancé
un appel à témoins et visionnent
actuellement les caméras de
vidéosurveillance de la ville alors ce
qui est absolument incroyable c'est que
quatre adolescents je dis bien
adolescents âgés de 15 à 18 ans ont été
arrêtés ils sont soupçonnés d'être les
auteurs des coups et blessures graves
ainsi que que du vol quelques chiffres
tout de même sur ces agressions et actes
homophobes en france en 2018 chaque jour
en france
une agression physique au dernier
trimestre chaque jour en france
une victime sur deux n'osent pas se
confier à ses proches et les attaques
violentes ont augmenté de 66% en 2018 on
va commencer par vous emilie lopez un
commentaire sur ce que vous venez de
voir de ce qui s'est passé à londres
forcément ça me touche personnellement
au cas où tout le monde n'aurait pas
compris je suis lesbienne donc forcément
c'est un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur je les trouve
très courageuse de témoigner je trouve
ça très bien encore les stigmates de ce
qu'elle a vécu un cadeau et quelques
jours après les images sont terribles là
ça se passe en angleterre mais en france
c'est exactement la même chose pour
ajouter aux chefs qu'on a pu montrer en
2018 ya une augmentation de 42% des
agressions lesbophobes 365,4 lesbophobes
en 2018 c'est bien par jour c'est vrai
que nous les lesbiennes
on ne s'en prend pas mal plein la tête
depuis quelque temps encore plus
qu'avant je sais pas pourquoi je ne sais
pas ce qui fait qu'on nous détestent
autant peut-être que on n'était pas
assez représenté aussi parce qu'il a pas
énormément de femmes lesbiennes qui sont
connus ce qui m'inquiète surtout c'est
que s'il y avait des activités dans les
médias ou chez les comédiens ou des jeux
devrait succéder entre guillemets porte
drapeau porte parole je pense que c'est
nécessaire moi je suis pas pour
j'aimerais bien que les cominois
n'existe plus j'aimerais bien qu'on
n'ait pas besoin de dire ce que je n'ai
pas besoin de vous il s'avère qu'on en a
besoin
moi toutes les fois où j'en parle
effectivement je me prends des insultes
et voire même déménagement mais surtout
je reçois beaucoup de messages de jeunes
filles qui me disent merci d'en parler
parce que je me retrouve en toi et ça me
fait du bien de te voir quand on coupe
tu es bien le souci c'est que là je vois
surtout que les agressions cd des
adolescents qui jouaient ça et moi c'est
ça qui me fait peur c'est que dans la
rue jose pu prendre la main de ma
compagne je n'ose pas regarder modifier
votre comportement bien évidemment il ya
quelques il ya quelques temps un soir ma
compagne rentrée il ya quelques années
est en fait elle s'est fait courser par
des jeunes qui l'insultait fort
heureusement était pas dans la maison et
donc du coup elle a pu rentrer assez
rapidement et du coup ça a complètement
changé notre notre façon d'être notre
façon de vivre et sa excès dus en sept
jours parce que aulas je marche dans la
rue avec elle j'ai envie de prendre la
main parce que je les aime et je peux y
faire naître plus dans dans l'eau là
vous allez dire dans l'instant mais dans
la réflexion de ce que je peux dans cet
endroit si écrire que ça pour être tout
à fait sincère je sais qu'un jour on va
se faire agresser
elle ou moi et je le sais et je sais que
ça arrivera je serai pas long mais ça ne
compte pas voilà les gars je suis vous
avez reçu proche de vous et à quel point
je vous accompagner et j'espère que ça
n'arrivera absolument jamais g6 faire
patienter les crimes ont argué que
vraiment voilà
et donc pour moi on est dans l'absurde
dans l'ubuesque je ne comprends pas
voilà ça c'est dans mon logiciel de
penser je ne comprends pas ce logiciel
là ça m'est étranger jean-michel une
réaction on ne questionne pas souvent
sur les motivations des gens qui font ça
il y en a une qui est terrible pour eux
ça veut dire que quelque part les
pulsions qu'ils ressentent même ça les
rend tellement hystérique ils en
viennent agresser les autres ce que je
veux dire par là c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont probablement des
pulsions homosexuelles très refoulés et
qui ne les exprime que quand exprimerait
de la violence à l'égard de ceux qui
sont réellement homosexuels donc ceux
qui font ça devrait se poser des
questions sur ce qu'ils pensent dans
leur tête et ce qu'ils sont réellement
sexuellement ça révèle de même mais oui
bien sûr oui caroline déjà
moi j'ai été très émue par ce qu'a dit
émilie et malheureusement je pense
qu'elle a raison dans le sens qu'on a
l'impression que c'est aujourd'hui
intégré en tout cas chez une grande
partie des gens je pense qu'en réalité
ça ne l'est pas et ça ce ça se prouve
par les chiffres parce que les chiffres
en fait sont grandissants en terme de
violences au nord c'est ce que ce que
disait me lis sur la jeunesse des
agresseurs puisqu'on peut imaginer que
on a on a souvent entendu dire oui mais
tu comprends il est d'une autre
génération s'avèrent papy c'est une
mamie il n'a pas été élevé comme ça
alors on est en 2019 les jeunes
générations elles sont baignées de
culture au cinéma à la télé on essaie en
tout cas je crois de de montrer que la
diversité c'est beau que vivre ensemble
c'est beau et c'est à cette seule
génération la semaine je l'entends pas
c'est à l'épi le réel et l'irréel et
pierre ya clairement un problème
d'éducation il ya un problème de
représentation et il ya un problème de
sanctions parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui encore avoir des sols
sont si faibles et si lente
on se croit autorisé est conscient on
finira toujours par s'en sortir même si
il ya une ou deux photos pour ces jeunes
générations n'ont pas intégré que
c'était un délit je pense que les jeunes
générations par des gangsters délits
comme le racisme d'ailleurs où on se dit
oh là là ça va c'est une petite phrase
par ci par là c'est très ordinaire après
tout ça me regarde si j'en ai pensé ça
alors que c'est un délit et les gens ne
le savent pas mais ils ont raison de ne
pas le savoir parce que la sanction
n'est jamais à la hauteur du délit
commis donc se mobiliser
il faut être sévère que légiférer
d'accord